Hello the world!
...
Wow, VR Chat... Is really cool
Music plays...
Top of the morning to you laddies!
How's it going there?
Where is the whiskey? Perhaps over here...
Player: There is no whiskey
Well, you don't sound-- wo wo wo wo wo
Thank you kind anime, princess
I'll be on my way now
[Laughs]
Player: Hello
Player: Welcome To The World Of Advetars
Was just leaving actually
But no no thank you, I'm crouched over, and I'm clenching real hard right now. I had really bad Mexican
That's okay, that's okay because I will just clean it myself. I really appreciate the other cab
Um no you can't do that either
Okay, well, that's illegal all right, so just back up. It's done illegal. It's it's to me all right
Okay, you're freaking me out
Nothing will go up my BOB
You're way too big at least let me change my avatar for this
At least I might make your cake look bigger if I go up your bum okay, that's just disturbing. Okay. All right. What if I?
All right, how about this huh how about this Oh God?
How are you going?
Hello can I get a hug hello? Oh, thank you
That was great hello everybody it's your boy wreck-it Ralph
Drink it Ralph huh, thanks goddamn right. I'm little round things I
Reckon to again I wreck your mamma's asshole how about
The headshot doing his side daddy stay away from me alright alright. I'm Ricky brown
That's fine. I don't wreck someone will wreck someone else's business cake you're scaring Peter. Just stick your skin
I am scared rivets at least get I don't know that's work, but I made it up. That's so scared I am
That is my drink
Good old record breaking things
Yes, that is a microaggression
Oh
You want to go
Prepare guys is way harder
He is so hot you're like
Spaghetti if I sweep, why would you do that to a lady?
Why don't you do that to the lady a lady and so sorry milady okay?
Treat treat me treat me with some respect
Okay, you you male privileged guy white?
Wreck-it Ralph don't you know my struggle? Did you not watch my movie?
I'm sorry someone had to say it. Oh wow doesn't this make you just feel like dancing
Hell yeah
No
That's right I get it now. I just kind of showed them my feet beer
It's cold you're breaking my immersion i'm so triggered
Oh
My god, it's Jar, Jar Binks everybody
What an honor to meet you it's Amis. Oh my god. It's the real one
the Italian one oh you sound like
Jacksepticeye that's right. I am jacksepticeye. How you found me you win a hug
Come here mr.. Jack brofist
That's not what jacksepticeye does all right of course
How you doing they're not fat look I can see in the mirror I can tell I'm not fat
I'm not fat. Okay. I'm not
Your beasts
Feels great excuse me I'm shaking it
Hey come on get up this magic
Please do love you get up I
Don't need it okay. Oh
My god
Yep look at all the anime girls are you doing?
Hey you doing that's very nice
Hello whole anime girls you wanna come with me oh
Thank you you and it you wanna go with Saliva's
Alright, you want to go with me. Hello. Hello wanna be my girlfriend so
Does anyone want to be my girlfriend?
Please
Please be my girlfriend
I'll do anything please and sorry assuming myself I
Will be your gum. I'll do anything
No one loves me
Please be my girlfriend someone oh
Hell yeah, oh hell yeah, that's what stuck in the back